I begged my brother for a Furby I begged
him and at the time there was so
expensive and he actually got me one for
Christmas
[Music]
there was this one toy that was called
sky dancers where you like hold on this
string and it flew up into the air
because it's like it's wings on the side
that did this I just remember the Furby
being the thing I guess it's like the
iPhone for adults oh my god this is like
funny true 90s version this is crazy
you're so huge hi you're so pretty you
have kind of a tease hair but you know
so do I this is kind of cute because I'm
I'm a little bit homesick and I miss my
brother so this is it's cool I didn't
know I do there's something about having
a doll and especially a life-size doll
like this is like your friend this is
the size of me oh come on so much is
flashing back to me right now I feel
like six year old least when I was a kid
I definitely had her play like different
things like I would be like today we're
adventure Barbie you were going on an
adventure
oh that one's way better okay we're
doing that one again I would do her hair
because I always have this crazy curly
hair and nobody ever had the same hair
as me that's the right way I don't even
know that's my kid all right
you didn't able me to do a lot of fun
creative things I made up stories for
you you got me through the doctor's
office visit so thank you for that I
appreciate you for that Barbie what was
so cool about these was that it gave you
the chance to look after something when
you wanna loud pets or babies sky
dancers are one of my favorites because
like you you could like control like how
high they went my brother and I still
talk about it to this day cuz it was
such a big deal for him to spend not
much money on a Christmas present for me
this is insane this is like the greatest
Christmas surprise give me back a piece
of my childhood it felt very magical
like Christmas magic this felt like
Christmas magic I think that I've always
been like an independent person from the
beginning it's like mom you don't have
to make food for me I got this i got my
easy-bake oven